there's a chance your produce has
traveled more than you have consider
that there are 2.6 million registered
truck trackers on us roads every day and
70% of all US agricultural products are
shipped by truck in fact the average
food item travels an estimated 5,000 120
miles through the supply chain before
reaching your store to learn more about
a crops travels to National Geographic
reporters followed a truck filled with
strawberries from field to store on may
5th the truck was one of 590 loaded up
at the Watsonville fields of Driscoll's
a leading US berry grower the trucks
cargo consisted of one pound of
strawberries per box eight boxes per
case 108 cases per pallet and twenty six
pallets per trailer altogether the cargo
was worth 90,000 dollars once loaded the
truck took off across the u.s. toward
its final destination
Washington DC long-haul truck drivers
decide their route and where to stop
bound only by their deadlines and an
emptying gas tank with a 240 gallon tank
to fill at least the fuel usually comes
with a free shower an 80 hour trip
accomplished in just three days by two
drivers the team takes turns sleeping
each legally driving no more than 11
hours per day every day this happens all
across America all those trucks passing
each other on the country's roads a
system so finely orchestrated that
consumers never have to think about
fruits journey until it arrives at the
store and shoppers can inspect their
berries for bruises